In this video, we are going to go over the interface.
So we will be looking at what all the different buttons do, and
how you can go about creating your first script.
So we have opened up our blueprint
here, for example, and you should be seeing
a screen which looks something like this.
We'll go over each section here. To start with, let's have a look
at the toolbar across the top here.
This is going to give us some kind of idea of the functionality.
So the first two buttons, which are pretty standard
amongst all of them, is the save.
It does what it says on the can. It just saves the file that we're working on
at that point in time. The one next to it might be
slightly less obvious, but this is going to allow us to browse to
the associated asset within the content browser.
So now, in order to get an asset into
a level, you'll often need to just drag it from the content
browser like this, but you might not be
in the correct directory, and projects can get quite complicated sometimes.
So an easy way to navigate to it
is just to click on this button here, and that's going to take us directly
to the Blueprint and allow us to drag it into the level. You will often also
see them in the details panel, where you're
going to be able to quickly browse just from
the reference in the details. Next up, you have the compile button.
Now, what compiling usually
does when you're working with a program is convert
a piece of code into a runnable form.
Now, Blueprints are slightly different. Mostly, this is
going to be doing a lot of checking to see
that what we have is runnable
and then it's going to convert it into something that we can run and
work within the level. You can see that at the moment we have a
green tick next to our compile, and the word's good to go.
So this means that this is working. This is fine.
However, if I was to come into the coding section here,
if I was to just add a section of code, I'm going to come off and do
a create widget.
Now we can see in the top left hand corner that we have
a yellow compile button. And if you look at the
tool tip, it says it's dirty and needs to be recompiled.
So at this point, we need to push the button to compile.
The third option is the red dot
compile, and this means that this has failed and there is an error in it.
If you look down, you've got compiler results, you'll see
that it'll give you a specific message telling you what the problem is,
and it'll also give you a button that means that you can navigate quickly.
So say I'm far away, you can navigate quickly to the problem.
In this instance, I have not actually selected a class
on this widget that I want to create. Don't worry too much about that.
We'll go over that in a minute. Again, we've got the three settings
and green is the good one that means you're good to go. Next up, we have
difference hid. Now this is part of the source
control. We're not going to touch on this in this thing, but this is going to allow you to look
at previously saved versions of the blueprints.
Next we have find. Pretty self-explanatory.
It's going to bring up a find results button here, and if I
type in a word, it will search through the code for references
to it. Now if I double-click, it's going to take me to
the appropriate mode.
Next up we have hide unrelated. Now I'll demonstrate this quickly,
but what this does is say
I had a program that had multiple notes,
something like this. If I have
hide unrelated ticked, you can see with the node that I have selected
at any one time, any node which is not connected
or which would not have an impact on the selected
node is going to be slightly greyed out. I'll just delete this.
Next up we have the class settings.
This goes back to us talking about inheritance. The class settings
in the class defaults. These are going to be in where you
can change or reset the variables
or the settings from the parent class which you've inherited.
Okay, simulation. This is actually hard
to demonstrate without. I would just add a couple of things to the world
so that we can see something. So what I've done
is I've added a static mesh component for a cube, and
I will add a rotating movement.
These are just two components, actor
components, which I've added in quickly to give us some functionality.
If I was to now hit the simulate button, you can see
within the viewport that the rotating movement
is just rotating the actor within the world.
So I will just stop that there. That allows you to just
simulate so you can see what's going on easily
within the viewport of the blueprints. Next
up are the play control buttons, and these are just exactly
the same as you will find in the main screen of the editor.
Now next up we have this drop
down box here. This has no debug object selected.
And this is going to allow us to
view the code so that we can see how the code is working at
any one time. The only problem is, in order to use this, we need
to know which instance we are viewing. So at the moment
we only have a singular instance within the world here.
So if I do the drop down, you can see that I have the selected
example. And so I'm going to select that one.
Now I'm going to add a little bit of code onto
Begin Play so that we can see it work. I'm just adding in three
delays, and I'm going to make each of these one second long.
And now, if I was to hit the play button, well with
the debug example selected, you can see
that it is giving us a visual interpretation of what the code is doing.
I'm going to stop that and replay. See again,
we are seeing the line light up. This means you can actually
watch the blueprint to see what's actually
happening with it at any point in time. Next up, in the
top left hand corner here, we have the components panel.
Now this is going to be a list of all of the different
components which have been added to your
blueprint. So you can see here that we added in the
cube, which is a static mesh component
which can be viewed now in the viewport here.
We also added in the rotating movement. Now this is
a good example of a
component which has no visual aspect to it. There's not a
child of an actor class. It doesn't have a transform.
However, the cube itself does. It just
has some functionality which would be applied to the blueprint.
In the top left hand corner of the components field, there is a
Add button. If you hit this, it's going to give you a list of
all of the different components that you are going to be able to
add. Below this is the My Blueprints
section. Now, if you've done any coding before,
you'd probably recognise this to look a bit like a header.
In this, we are going to define what
different events and functions and macros
and variables that are connected
to the coding. This will be more useful, more
valuable when we actually jump into the coding section of this.
Now, on the right hand side, we have a details panel. The details
panel is common across all of the different sections of
Unreal Engine. This is a contextual menu.
When you have different things selected, the details are going to
change accordingly for the different settings that you've had. You can
view this, for example, if I was to click on one of the components
or one of the variables, we are going to get different values
in the details panel, allowing us to change how they are set up.
Now, in the centre, we have a
viewport. Now, this viewport functions very
much like the viewport that we all have inside
the main Unreal Engine window.
You are going to be able to move around it in a very similar way.
So if I hold down the right hand mouse button, I'm going to be able to change the rotation
of my editor camera, and whilst I have
the right hand mouse button held down,
I'll be able to use the W-A-S-D to move around
the world to see things from a different angle. You'll find
the majority of the other keys work in this as well. You'll also
see that we have a number of different menus in the top left hand corner, in the top
right hand corner. These will correspond to
the similar menus in the main viewport.
In the top left hand corner, we will have some settings so that we can
change the way that this scene is displayed, and in
the top right hand corner, we're going to be able to change the way we can
interact with the scene. So the first thing that we've got are the different
modes of changing between selecting objects,
translating and moving objects, rotating and scaling.
We are also going to have the
snapping percentages on the right hand side. So by clicking on these
buttons, you can turn them on or off to
prevent the need to have to snap to those numbers. We also have the
camera speed, which can be also controlled by
right hand mouse button, and using the middle mouse button to roll
up and down to speed up how fast and slow the camera
moves. Now next to the viewport, we will have
two separate coding graphs.
We will have the construction script and the event graph. Now
if we are to click on these,
we will see that we have a number of different
nodes. So this is where we're going to be actually doing our
coding. Now, navigating around
this is an interesting topic. So
the first thing is, if you want to move within these,
if you place the mouse over the background and hold down
the right hand mouse button, you'll see that the mouse cursor
converts to a small hand. This will allow you to
drag around the scene. Whilst this hand
is present, you can scroll the middle mouse wheel
in and out, and this will allow you to zoom in and
zoom out of the code that you're looking at.
Next up, we have the construction script. This functions in a very
similar way to the event graph. It just fires at a slightly different
time. What we will do in the next video is we're going
to go over how you can create code and
place nodes within the editor, and we will be going into these
sections in much more detail then.